welcome to this video playing zoo rap no
sirree up okay I don't you try to figure
out what that means ok let's go with g6
something that's good very often g6 is a
very decent set up against those some
those somewhat slowish buildups like the
one he was the doc the one he has him so
I'm basically getting a modern benoni
here with e3 played this has recently
become a bit more popular this is set up
to avoid a Greenfeld type of positions
but still it's a and it's a benoni with
them with the tempo tempo up for blacken
so do you go a six or maybe like this
first I interesting hmm right it's seven
then hmm yeah maybe write a 76 is an
idea you so Bishop
we should be seven and it looks a bit
bit weird Bishop d7 I'd suffice the
uncomfortable looking situation really
hmm
okay i have forgot to ask scott Bishop
c4 him I saw that before but Bishop c4
was my original problem with that okay
so maybe I have to do this really and
now see see what to do b6 and d6s
hanging v5p 596 d5 Knight b6
yeah maybe that one at least thats its
active mm-hmm Chad they don't even think
that this is that great time I'm getting
some stuff back here so I get this check
in may be the shadows and now it here in
takes is 60 this is not a problem at all
he played that very very quickly I don't
know I thought some precision was
probably helpful for what but this this
should be okay again I've got very
active pieces so he wants to go and be
formed quite quite clearly so Queen
takes before maybe the 95 yeah that is
interesting oops no just there okay yeah
so let's go 95 for night be four or 93
dark squares
that's can I can pre means that not
don't think it's very likely to happen
but
and I was investing time so night night
before didn't didn't seem to be a
problem jam but ok I'm going here that's
the dark squared control he is quite
nice just wonder if there's any headway
to be made to be made here hmm it's
actually not so easy that's the easy to
go to get somewhere this Bishop on c4 is
always covering it too
I don't know h5 edge for something like
that I have to be cautious screen text
g67 this is something I should be very
about and now he wants to check on g4
play Bishop f7 hmm so let's move the
Queen way out of all of that idea ok
let's go here now yes he's attacking
what nothing really ok that push age 44
h three so we cannot go h3 here i can
take and then aged three that's probably
a draw Rugare three is not working i can
play the rope here nice got to go in
between age six maybe okay I'm so big
and go here ty morning I'll keep it
simple method Jack shakes and it's it's
just equal it's a bit of a bit more
comfortable for black because office
save a king but it's still of course
it's equal and going to be drawn check I
one nurses some some way forward gym
probably not
check it's a bit surprising she actually
allowed that but it's still still
nothing okay Queen Queen doesn't have
that many squares of off to hear
Bishop g5f wise mine
hmm now probably still nothing can shake
their but it's also a bit risky check
okay I should have just taken the wrong
as usual I could have taken Asia to
check yeah of course he noticed that he
wins on time so it doesn't try to play
with moose this is the typical thing
Jack diddly dead position gras our third
black forfeits one time okay i did was
provisional so it only cost me six
points Jim dad didn't didn't really make
much of my chances this was a nice
position here really nice maybe you
cannot win and so it's possible check
jenn-air just subtract it's really just
a draw probably check check yes no
particular or Bishop b5 why didn't I
play that one f5 looked interesting but
I could have done that that would have
given real winning chances actually wow
man that's much better for black
actually he has to do this now okay yeah
that probably that probably can be one
with Queens on the board check check
made to draw the whole time when she can
of course them can do this through this
time play check check you know it's a
complete row okay well thanks for
watching